[Musik]
zusammen mit der rechtsanwältin ayse
celik wollen wir eine frau besuchen die
von der türkischen justiz seit fast
einem jahr festgehalten wird
ohne anklage ohne gerichtsverfahren die
wohnung im dritten stock das ist der
hausarrest für commerce deutsche
staatsbürgerin
die türkische staatsanwaltschaft glaubt
sie sei eine terroristin
sie darf die wohnung nicht verlassen
es gelten regeln wie im frauengefängnis
besuch ist erlaubt ton und filmaufnahmen
verboten
sie hat schaden durch den hausacher
stuff on getragen ein jahr ihres lebens
hat sie verloren hat die zeit vergeudet
mit diesem unsinn
ich denke dass sie schwer traumatisiert
ist ich weiß nicht wie lange sie das
noch durchhalten wird das trauma ist im
moment sehr groß von unserem treffen mit
google earth fertigen die zeichnungen an
zitieren aus unseren gesprächsnotizen
was habe ich in diesem land verbrochen
warum nimmt man mir mein leben weg ich
habe keine kontrolle mehr über mein
leben
das ist das schlimmste sie muss eine
elektronische fußfessel tragen die
polizei alarm auslöst uns erzählt sie
dass sie schon zweimal versucht haben
sich das leben zu nehmen
im mai 2009 10 sei sie bei der einreise
in die türkei festgenommen worden
man werfe ihr unterstützung der pkk vor
lasse sie nicht ausreisen
ich war vorher jahrelang immer wieder in
die türkei gekommen ohne probleme und
plötzlich dass eine acht jahre alte
polizeiakte aus deutschland halten sie
mir vor ein foto aus der polizei akteurs
im april 2012
es geht um einen vorfall in ihrer
heimatstadt köln auf dem ausflugsschiff
colonia sechs demonstrieren ist und neun
andere junge aktivisten mit einem
transparent für hungerstreikende kurden
sie bringen das schiff für wenige
momente in ihre gewalt
die polizei beendete den protest die
schifffahrtsgesellschaft hält ihn für so
harmlos dass sie auf eine strafanzeige
verzichtet
doch in ankara informiert der bka
verbindungsbeamten der deutschen
botschaft umgehend die türkischen
ermittler nur fünf tage nach dem vorfall
am 20 04 2011 12 schreibt der bka mann
zitat betrifft besetzung von zwei
schiffen in köln und hamburg durch pkk
kämpfer am 15 04 2011 12 um 14 uhr 45
bestiegen 10 kurdische militante das
ausflugsschiff colonia 6
der bka-beamte macht die kölner
demonstranten kurzerhand zur pkk
kämpfern und kurdischen militanten er
ruft damit die türkischen ermittler auf
den plan
man sieht ja im fall groer sehr deutlich
welche dramatischen folgen vielleicht
eine unbedachte informationsweitergabe
haben kann die dann am ende politisch
für eigene zwecke durch die türkische
seite missbraucht wird
in diesem fall steht halt eben zu
befürchten dass deutsche
sicherheitsbehörden praktisch ungewollt
auch noch dafür gesorgt haben dass ist
diese weitreichenden folgen hat dabei
ist für die kölner staatsanwaltschaft
schnell klar grass ist wieder eine
kurdische militante noch eine pkk
kämpferin in einem brief vom november
2012 zeit die staatsanwältin mit das
ermittlungsverfahren habe ich
eingestellt
im hausarrest sagt uns google earth
das verfahren wurde eingestellt weil ich
nichts verbrochen habe damit war die
sache für mich erledigt nicht aber für
die türkische justiz die will nun noch
viel mehr informationen über die
demonstranten fragt deutschland an das
bundesinnenministerium in berlin
behauptet heute auf die nachfrage der
türkei seien keine weiteren
informationen geflossen das türkische
behörden überhaupt informiert wurden
rechtfertigt das ministerium auf eine
parlamentsanfrage so zitat seitens des
bundeskriminalamts sind keine
personenbezogenen daten an türkische
behörden übermittelt worden
trotzdem wenig später tauchen details
aus deutschen ermittlungsakten in
türkischen dokumenten auf und so wird
gelöst ein in deutschland eingestelltes
verfahren jahre später in der türkei zum
verhängnis wie ihr geht es offenbar
vielen deutscher staatsbürger wir haben
65 menschen deutsche staatsbürger die in
den gefängnissen sitzen in der türkei
und 71 die die ausreisesperre haben das
heißt also mit fußfessel oder ähnliche
dinge dort an der ausreise gehindert
werden und das geht meines erachtens gar
nicht die türkische regierung droht
offen dass die politische gegner auch im
ausland beobachtet um sie in der türkei
zu verfolgen
[Musik]
es gibt leute die in deutschland oder
europa an kundgebungen einer
terrororganisation teilnehmen und dann
nach antalya oder nach bodrum kommen um
urlaub zu machen
für die haben wir jetzt maßnahmen
getroffen diese menschen werden bei der
einreise festgenommen und ab geht's mit
ihnen und dabei helfen wissentlich oder
nicht auch deutsche ermittlungsbehörden
es kann nicht sein dass ein
unrechtsstaat wie es die türkei in
meinen augen gegenwärtig ist information
von unseren sicherheitsbehörden erhält
um dort mögliche einreisende kurden oder
auch linke türken sofort verhaften zu
können in deutschland treffen wir die
anwältin von günthers wieder
sie will einblick nehmen in die akten
von damals in der hoffnung etwas zu
finden was ihrer mandantin in der türkei
hilft anwalt boris jesih will ihr helfen
er vertrag damals andere demonstranten
von der colonia 6 alle haben angst die
haben alles um ihre existenz in
deutschland die haben angst um ihre
familien
deswegen halten sich auch bedeckt und
zurück wenn der name auftaucht in
welches zu haben so was zusammenhang
auch immer dann würden auch die familien
der türkei probleme bekommen
unser zelt gelöst dass sie unter
depressionen leide vor angst und
verzweiflung nur noch mit tabletten
schlafen könne festgekettet in der
türkei ist dieses leben in deutschland
zerbrochen
ihr einkommen ist weg einige freunde
auch ganz langsam entfernen sich meine
träume von mir mein leben entfernt sich
von mir und ich kann nur dasitzen und
zusehen und kann nichts dagegen tun
können erstes zum opfer der türkischen
politik geworden die kurden weit über
die eigenen grenzen hinaus verfolgt zum
opfer auch deutsche behörden die dabei
mithelfen